[Music]
now the next thing we want to talk about
is dementia is how many have ever heard
of alzheimers disease raise your hand
okay good
now alzheimers disease is a physician
cause disease it's not genetic
alzheimers disease is a physician cause
disease that is not genetic now you're
not the mom of a doctor are you okay now
listen my wife is a surgeon I love
doctors I love doctors and they do have
their place but in this case doctors
have caused this disease 40 years ago
alzheimers disease didn't exist even by
another name alessandra disease did not
exist 40 years ago even by another name
today it's the number four killer of
adults over the age of 65 so just a
short period of time has become a huge
huge problem for industrialized
countries 85% of all alzheimers disease
is diagnosed in the world I'm gonna
repeat that 85% of all alzheimers
disease diagnosed in the world is
diagnosed in America it's an American
disease created by American doctors
because 75% of your brain weight is a
fatty insulation material called myelin
how many of you heard of myelin okay
good
it myelin makes up 75% of your brain
waves the white matter of the brain the
gray matter the the thinking cells and
the memory cells sitting on top of the
white matter which is this white fatty
insulation material makes up 75 percent
of your brain weight and when the myelin
goes away you get alzheimers disease
because the naked nerve fiber is all
shard out and they look for nerve
tangles with cat-scans and that's how
they diagnose Alzheimer's disease well
elm disease is caused by this myelin
going away myelin makes up 75% of your
brain weight and myelin is a hundred
percent cholesterol so if you're on a
cholesterol restricted diet you're
taking cholesterol-lowering drugs guess
what you're going to get alzheimers
disease so you have to dump the
cholesterol-lowering drugs you have to
start eating 10 eggs a day no fried
foods no margarine there's no cooking
oils and yeah and take the mighty 90 you
take the mighty 90 and the odds of you
getting Alzheimers
these is zero zero don't you think about
your grandparents they've all the eggs
and all the cook and they did in lard
and everything they didn't have
Alzheimers disease they died at ninety
210 stuff like that okay next this is
the US News will report February of this
year 2010 and they're talking about the
80 million baby boomers come along
living be 100 that upper right hand
corner there it's a summary of one of
the chapters it says 7 habits that you
can do to lower your risk of Al's and
Rosie's that tells you right there that
alzheimers disease is not genetic
because there's no habit you can do this
can reduce the risk of a genetic disease
see they know it seven habits that you
can do this to reduce your risk of
getting Alzheimer's disease don't eat
fried foods don't eat processed meats
with nitrates and nitrites take the
mighty 90 and you won't get it next
that's just some of that myelin shows
all that fatty stuff around those nerve
fibers next there's a tidal wave coming
of Alice Hunter disease because there's
80 million baby boomers coming along who
did whatever the doctors told them I
want to live to be 100 I'm a baby boomer
we want to be the first generation where
everybody loves me 100 will you lower
your cholesterol and you'll live to be
100 give me give me give me I want the
newest I want the newest plus for a
lowering drug give me an overdose of
that one doc mm-hmm
well the unintended consequence is lo T
Edie and if you could remember
alzheimers disease next
cost $12,000 a month to maintain and
Alzheimers patient and you're gonna pay
for it you were literally gonna pay for
it out of your social security checks
when you get there next yeah let's see
oh yeah Alzheimers in an unrelenting
upward trajectory and again they're
picking on the baby boomers because
they're the ones taking all the
cholesterol-lowering drugs and eating
that cholesterol restricted diet next
ultra fat dad is actually therapeutic
I've been doing this for things like MS
multiple sclerosis lou gehrig's disease
Parkinson's disease dementia including
Alzheimer's disease totally preventable
know people like Muhammad Ali we could
actually solve his problem but you can't
get to him because he's got all these
layers of agents and representatives and
stuff so you can't get to him to help
him right but any rate I talked about 65
percent of the calories in your diet
having to come from good fats eggs red
meat not processed meat but you know
good steak every day your pound a
hamburger or a day keeps the doctor away
kind of thing and they said okay we're
gonna show wallach wrong what they found
out was they could get rid of all those
diseases by giving in 90 percent of your
calories coming from fat 90 percent of
your calories can that's from the
Medical School of New York City next
this came out in 1992 it said that just
vitamin E alone could actually help
people to advance the Alzheimer disease
vitamin E alone can actually help people
with Alzheimer's disease just 1 out of
the 90 and nobody wanted to believe that
this study was done by the University of
California San Diego and the Salk
Institute that made the Salk vaccine I
mean we're talking about respectable
institutions here there was a big
firestorm over that because when I read
that title in 1993 I said and that means
it cannot be genetic
there was actually a firestorm set off
in the media by that presentation I gave
and so they
universities and the Salk Institute
redid it next slide please
five years later the headline was bigger
vitamin E might slow a Alzheimer's
disease you can same agencies it's
getting bigger here now the next one and
I'll have to tell you what this says
Johns Hopkins University where that
terrible event happened today John
Hopkins University up in Baltimore
Maryland they did a study in Cache
County Utah they picked Cache County
Utah because these were all Mormon
farmers these guys all ate the same diet
they're all very faithful to the
religious dietary laws and they live 10
years longer than the average American
they lived the 85 instead of 75
they gave half of them of 5000 of these
people for a 10-year period just vitamin
C and vitamin E they got crazy over the
nutrients they so they gave two instead
of one instead of 90 they gave two
vitamin C and E and the other half they
gave a sugar pill nobody knew who got
their sugar pill and who got the
vitamins well at the end of the ten
years the ones who got the vitamin C and
the vitamin E were 78 percent less
likely to get Al's never disease and the
ones that just got the sugar reduce your
risk of balancing heart disease by 80
percent by just taking two of the mighty
90 if I don't see him vitamin E what if
you take all 90 and avoid the fried
foods and eat your ten eggs a day the
odds of you getting alessandra disease
is zero and please please please don't
say that sounds kind of interesting I'm
gonna ask my doctor
you mean the person who's gonna live to
be 56 ooh ouch okay next look at that
just eating good fish like salmon twice
a week reduce your risk of a heart
disease because you're gonna get two of
the 90 essential nutrients the omega-3s
and omega-6s right in the right ratios
next big study in New York gosh just
eating a healthy diet reduces your risk
of Alzheimer's disease that's not like a
genetic disease do you know cannot be
it's impossible to be genetic with
articles like that study on 2,000 people
from New York next okay and so we
already know how to avoid alzheimers
disease there's actually four dimensions
there's senile dementia which is now
called vaster dementia because there's
nothing wrong with the brain the
arteries are clogged and then there is
Korsakoff syndrome which I can cure that
in two weeks I don't cure it because it
looks like alzheimers disease but it's
actually a symptom of a thiamine vitamin
b1 deficiency people eating lots of
sugar no thiamine and it looks like
alzheimers disease but you just get rid
of the sugar and you give them the
mighty nine and it goes away in two
weeks it's a miracle
then there's Wernicke korsakoff's
disease where it's actually a mess
multiple sclerosis and Korsakoff
syndrome that's easy to take care of and
then of course there's alzheimers
disease so I like to nutritionally treat
them and prevent them by giving
everything that would cover all four
don't try and cherry-pick one well I'm
gonna prevent else on Rosie's you get
the other three right so you don't
cherry-pick it okay next